uh my number two do or don't
bring stupid
don't be stupid
so
every year
at camp nut butter i purposely tried to
bring something a little bit more stupid
than the year before
and it just makes camp more fun
whether it's an outfit that is really
stupid
bring it if it's something for camp
that's really stupid bring it
don't bring food
bring stupid
just don't be stupid
don't be the stupid guy who's causing
all the problems who's starting a fire
who's uh you know doing karaoke at 4 00
am uh also by the way
bring stupid
just not the karaoke machine keep the
karaoke machine at home
it's the only thing i'd say don't break
don't bring a karaoke mission so we
started with um if you don't know camp
nut butter it all started because we
were all you know just camping with each
other and i
hated it
frankly i absolutely hated the camping
experience i didn't want anything to do
with it so if i wanted to be in this
place that i loved so much
listening to all these these bands that
i loved so much i had to figure out a
way to make this work for me
so
i pitched to everybody at the campsite
hey why don't we um
why don't we get some carpet and uh some
sofas and a bigger tent
and they all looked at me like i was
insane
i was ridiculed i mean laughed out of
of the entire festival
until the next year when i brought
700 square feet of carpeting
a giant 20 by 20 wedding tent
all of the the creature comforts that
the chase uh the chaise lounge the uh
the chest of drawers the sofa when i
started bringing all that that the
coffee table
what did all of you say
you all said this is so stupid why would
you ever do this this is not camping man
what is it and then what do all of you
love
10 years later 15 years later
we still make fun of you and think
you're stupid um that's that's never
going to change but yeah we we
appreciate
or most of them probably do that you
bring all of that my problem is that
it's become my it's your job now yes
that's job yeah yeah yeah hey barry come
by and get carpeted
yeah
guess who has the couch
me
so guess who's got to bring the company
the uh so then the next year after that
i decided why don't we make this disney
world and really make this thing goofy
so that's when i got everybody's giant
head made into a cartoon we blew it up
and we put it on sticks all around the
campsite and not only that but i made a
twister board with everybody's cartoon
head on twister so we had camp nut
butter twister um then we created a
giant lit marquee that you could walk
under that was solar powered so at night
it would flash at you
um i bought i mean
yards and yards and yards and yards of
white picket fencing to put around the
entire thing
um we've got a long
you know row what is that thing that
we'd say it's like something from a
wedding that you brought one year barry
that's our it's our yeah our i never
camping i don't it's like not too old
but yeah and then so year after year
it's a runway
it's that yeah it's like a runway it's a
runway and so every year we just keep
adding stupid to this a couple years ago
we added a mailbox a giant camp nutmeg
mailbox that we nailed into the ground
and we put a recorder inside of the
mailbox so that anybody that opened it
will leave us a voice message on youtube
yeah that's right so you know that's the
kind of we then realize that everybody
at camp loves
um bloody mary's so we have a tent just
dedicated to bloody mary's because they
get sticky and dirty and we want to keep
that over there then we have a tenth
that's just for a kitchen
um there was one year that we only had a
tent just for the podcast uh taco shows
up he's got the bus
it really is a goofy experience but the
more fun and stupider you make it i
promise you the better it's going to be